i'm wolfgang puck and i own a few
restaurants and i'm gonna cook chicken
pot pie it's old style cooking in a way
like comfort food often comes from your
grandmother you don't want the flour to
brown so it should stay nice and
off-white steer it frequently because if
not it will stick now let me show you
what i like about the consistency you
take a spoon put a streak too you still
see the soup spoon underneath but the
sauce covered the spoon perfectly the
same way then in our dish the most
important thing really when you make the
sauce is then to taste it but a little
more salt you also can add a little
cream to it to make it even more rich
there should be no way that anywhere you
go in your home or restaurant that
something is under seasoned or over
season
you can add any vegetables you have i
think in the winter time we have a lot
of root vegetables like you could add
parsnips to it you can add celery root
to it whatever you find at the local
store or on the farmer's market
you don't have to cut it in perfect
circle it's okay if it's a little oval
or whatever the most important thing is
that it's bigger than your bowl
also if you don't have chicken you could
make the same thing with turkey for
example leftover turkey would be perfect
here is our truffle it's really a very
special location i bought one once in
italy for 19 dollars one and we spend
hundreds of thousands of dollars for
diamonds and you cannot even eat it
you know what i like about the chicken
pot pie is the presentation also when
you take it out of the oven and it has
this beautiful brown dome people are
gonna say what is this and then they're
gonna dig in it and you get this all the
flavors coming out
some things will never go out of fashion
people love chicken but pine oh yes